I got a section about how you gotta be
careful with your words as a leader you
must be careful not to gossip not to
become too familiar casual or unguarded
with your troops gossip sarcasm and
flippant remarks all carry too much
weight when thrown around by the leader
ribbing comments that might seem
harmless among friends can have a real
impact on a subordinate even legitimate
criticism needs to be delivered with
caution preferably in private so that
dignity is maintained this is not to say
that critical mistakes should not be
reviewed so the whole team can learn but
criticism must be constructive and aimed
at not an individual's potential but at
the specific mistakes themselves this is
I'll do this all because you know I'll
be sitting around joking around with
everyone and we'll be having a good time
and I'll throw his anger at someone and
I'll be like yeah that was an uncool you
know and sometimes I'm wanting that I
won't even realize and I'll I don't have
to think about it and I'll say oh yeah I
what conversation did you and I have
about being an asshole
I was like hey Dave you know like I'm an
asshole and I have to basically muzzle
that we've had several times had it
several times and and you have thrown
some zingers out where I've given you
the look like well that was an asshole
move right there yeah and you're like
yes it was perhaps worth it maybe not
but yeah that's one of those I I realize
this you know there's two there's two
ends to this one end is when you're in a
leadership position you don't realize
the weight of your compliments and you
don't realize the weight of your
criticisms so you might not think saying
hey echo that video looked great you
know or whatever you might be might
think I'm not gonna tell that go because
I don't care hey the videos video is
good to go but he knows that no it's
like yeah it actually carries weight and
and I won't forget that all day long
I'll be
and basically it's a it's a lack of
awareness of like hey I'm actually like
in an elevated position in this team
whatever I'll make that mistake you know
I made it I would make this mistake at
trade you know when I was
or in task unit bruiser but I would make
the mistake but as I started to
understand I realized hey you need to be
careful with your words you need to be
careful you need to understand the
weight of the impact of the things that
you're saying both positive and negative
because they carry weight that you may
or may not understand from that
leadership position